now today is nelson mandela day and it
comes at a time when many south africans
may be looking at the state of their
nation
and wondering what the world's favorite
revolutionary would make of it
the jailing of former south african
president jacob
zuma earlier this month sparked
widespread riots and looting
with well over a hundred people killed
it's the worst
unrest seen in post-apartheid south
africa
so where does the rainbow nation go from
here i'm joined now by equality
campaigner and the eldest daughter
of nelson mandela dr makazui mandela
good morning dr mandela what is the
message of nelson mandela day
the message of nelson mandela day is
about working together to address the
iniquities
to address poverty to do everything
as individuals to create a better life
for somebody
else and that's the message of nurse
mandela day because no one person
no one organization can actually be able
to address
the social injustice the poverty that is
in society
you need a lot of people to come
together uh
individuals organizations government
to try and change this world to be a
better place for all
we're a long way from the
action that you're seeing some of it uh
extremely unpleasant we'll come to that
in a moment
but what would you like people uh out
here
in europe and north america to be doing
to celebrate this day
i think for me trevor as i look around
the world
um where we have uh and the coverage
which is plaguing a lot of people and as
just as i listen
a lot of people are losing their jobs
and
and there's a resurgence of racism
and ethnicism around the world i think
coverage has exabated the iniquities in
society
and i think nelson mandela day is about
reminding
us of the challenges that are ahead of
us
and i think for me uh covered 19 has
shown that
humanity is capable of actually
helping each other to try and create
a better environment society and that if
we are not going to work together
and and hold hands
whether it's in the sort of rich
northern
and emerging south or the west we all
need to work together
basically i think that's the message of
of nelson mandela international day
well you you talked about the scourge of
covid and over the last year it has been
the greatest challenge to south africa
and across africa
actually infections have surged uh by
about 43
in the space of a week um what does
africa and south africa
in particular need in order to be able
to meet that challenge
now i think the most important thing as
we have realized is that
we need and
because the rich westerners
has actually bought all the vaccines and
the emerging economies have better
looking of the vaccines
you know the social distancing i think
south africa did well
in the first phase of college and to
some extent
a little bit better in the second wave
of the coming but
and that third wave is is becoming
more brutal on society mainly because
you know uh we have a lot of people who
are in in poverty
don't have the same access to to health
and
uh you know vaccines are very scarce
around the world
and so we are faced with
multiple challenges in south africa
and the one for africa
in terms of a vaccine and allowing some
of the
of the vaccines to be manufactured in
africa
can i turn to uh some more divisive
issues
um we've seen over the last year a
wave of concern anxiety protest
over racism a year ago the whole world
was talking about black lives matter
what do you think your father would be
saying about all of that were he alive
today
i think my father would be repeating
what he said
when he was alive that the struggle is
not
actually complete and that we should not
tire
we should press on to fight racism with
everything that we have
in our might and and that there needs to
be
much more dialogue on on on racism
because it's plaguing the whole world
america uk um south africa
we still have a lot of after effects of
apartheid that we are killing
uh it's in europe i i think
my father would be saying we've got to
all put our heads together and fight the
sketch of racism
until it ends let's turn to south africa
itself today i i was um on
television doing this job many years ago
when your father came out of poles more
prison and i uh commentated on it
with taboo and becky who became his
deputy and the first president
and i don't think on that day anybody
imagined though we knew things would be
difficult that south africa would be
where it is today
question i really want to ask you is is
this for the last 27 years the movement
that your father
and oliver tambo created the african
national
congress has been in government how much
of what is happening today
is the anc's responsibility
i would say all of which is actually the
responsibility of the aec
um the anc seems to have
forgotten why it came into power it came
into power mainly because
it wanted to improve the conditions and
lives of black people
who have been impoverished they are
dignity taken away by the apartheid
regime
political freedom was never enough
my father knew it they knew it and
we cannot leave the economy that
supported apartheid
to be intact because there is no way
therefore
to redress the iniquities of the past
and address the conditions of the poor i
i mean if you look
at the conditions of the poor in south
africa
who are mainly black and it has not
improved
alexander when my death stage when he
came to join respect he's still the same
which has not improved
simple things like providing adequate
housing
water and clean services
has been something that this government
has failed actually our people in terms
to deliver
and so um what is happening right now
is squarely in their hands as my father
said
before with apartheid they cannot go on
forever
looking at peaceful means and the
government doesn't hear
those who are poor who have not
benefited from what i call the
post-apartheid dividend
have been poor for more than 300 years
their father their generations their
grandfather their great grandfather
how long should they wait until
conditions improve for them
nobody a trevor i want to assure you
wants to see south africa in the
situation of violence
but unless south africa squarely address
the issues of poverty and inequity
youth unemployment which is hovering at
about 74
south africa will see more of this
violence occurring
more and more dr mandela
thank you very much in indeed um i hope
today
uh is a good day for you at least thank
you
thank you very much